president biden is stumbling downstairs
and crowding migrant children into cages
but his approval ratings are golden
the establishment media turn over the
keys to ibram x kennedy and another woca
culture warrior has a guilty past i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
and we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and plenty of news
there is but we begin with the fact that
the currency is about to be inflated i
mean let's should be real about this the
way the government is spending is not
sustainable and that means you need to
diversify away from things like bonds
and into something a little bit more
solid i of course i'm talking about
precious
metals i've been telling you about birch
gold group for the past five years i buy
my gold from birch gold
and so do you i'm really excited because
birch gold has just passed a major
milestone ten
thousand customers that is ten thousand
people who have a plan against radical
leftist policies driving up our national
debt devaluing the dollar if you've been
waiting to call birch gold to convert an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira backed
by gold and silver now would be an
excellent time
through april 30th on qualifying
purchases when you purchase precious
metals with birch gold they'll send you
a free home safe
with giving away books silver this is
their biggest giveaway ever
so here's the thing larry summers former
secretary of the treasury under bill
clinton
he says we are now watching the worst
fiscal policy in four decades do not be
a victim of that fiscal policy instead
diversify into precious metals text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free information
kit on precious metals iras or to speak
with a birch gold representative today
with 10 000 customers they've got an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews they
can help you as well text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free safe with
purchase
today alrighty so just before the
weekend
joe biden had an unfortunate run-in with
some stairs
and this video was basically blacked out
on all of american national tv
international tv covered it but joe
biden who's 78 years old
let it not be forgotten here the man is
78 years old he's obviously in somewhat
frail health every time he speaks for
longer than about a couple of sentences
you feel your guts start to churn i mean
it's to the point where you can't
even really mock like you feel bad
mocking because the guy is 78 years old
and honestly like a lot of 78 year old
people
have trouble going upstairs the way the
joe biden obviously has some trouble
going up these stairs
so you can see here joe biden climbing
up the stairs of air force one there's a
little bit of a breeze but this is not
like hurricane
gales here once twice and down
down goes frasier so picks himself up
kind of limps his way
back up to the top so the white house
naturally blamed
the wind for this this was not the wind
this was joe biden slipping now listen
so i think slipping on the stairs is the
world's biggest deal
i don't think it's the biggest deal but
i will point out that joe biden has
prided himself on his peak physical
condition
for well over a couple of years now he's
been challenging people in the crowd to
fight
he challenged president trump to like a
push-up contest or something and you'll
remember that when donald trump went
down a ramp slowly
when he took little steps to go down a
ramp and there was mockery about how he
was afraid of stairs joe biden jumped
right in on that so
i guess that if you're going to be a
jerk like joe biden was then apparently
you know what goes around comes around
look at how he steps and look how i
stepped
watch how i run up ramps and he stumbles
down ramps
okay come on come on okay well um
you fell down on the stairs three times
in one flight of stairs
so there's that remember folks that the
entire comedic establishment has decided
there is nothing funny
here you're not allowed to make fun of
joe biden there's nothing not even
saying you're not allowed there's
nothing funny about him
he's just so serious and so
clear and so with it you can't make fun
of of the president of the united states
it's impossible according to our
comedians the same people who said that
gerald ford a former all-american
football player
was a klutz and a bozo because he fell
down
stairs right that literally they made
fun of him for like several years on snl
because of that
you remember that bob dole was
considered a kooky older klutz
because he fell off the stage bob dole
was 73
joe biden is 78 so it just demonstrates
the kind of double standard that
joe biden is being treated to and of
course it is that double standard that
is responsible for the fact that his
approval ratings
are extremely high right now joe biden's
are are by pretty much every measure
significantly higher
than president trump's even then
president obama's at this point in his
presidency i believe
according to gallup president biden has
averaged 56 job approval across three
gallup polls since taking office
including 54 in the latest survey from
march 1st to 15th
there's a yawning party gap pretty much
all democrats approve and pretty much
all republicans disapprove which is not
a shock that's the way this stuff works
now
but his job ratings differ significantly
by gender education race and place of
residence and that is because
joe biden speaks the vocabulary okay so
let it never be forgotten as long as you
speak the vocabulary you can be as
garbage at your job as it is possible to
be
and you will still be treated as though
you are a wondrous wondrous politician
because you say the right things
and you can see this in the way that the
the
demographic breakdowns go in terms of
who really likes joe biden
so women really like trouble he's got a
62 approval rating with women 62 to 34.
men he's only up 49.45 which seems a lot
more accurate to me maybe that's because
i'm a man among white americans he
actually has a disapproval rating
45 to 52 among black americans
89 to 8 which is again pretty reflective
of party differences
among hispanics 73 to 17
if you look at college graduate versus
non-college graduate because joe biden
speaks the equity language
which is what you're indoctrinated with
in college remember colleges these days
are not about providing you a skill set
so you can actually enter the
marketplace
colleges provide two things they are a
feeder mechanism
they sort they're a sorting mechanism so
they allow you to see whether someone is
quote unquote smart or not by what
college they went to so there it's
about credentialing and on the other
hand they allow you to speak
in the language that the upper crust new
ruling class speak
in america and so college graduates look
at joe biden he speaks that language
trump didn't
and therefore he's at 64 in the approval
ratings versus only 51 percent
for people who are not college graduates
he has heavy support among the young
66 percent of people aged 18 to 29
support joe biden compared to only 51
percent of people over the age
of 65. so are these huge gaps
in approval rating for joe biden utterly
disconnected from his performance by the
way
because his performance so far has been
pretty abysmal in fact his performance
has been so abysmal that he has now been
relegated to telling george
stephanopoulos the sycophantic
quasi reporter for abc news that you
know what you know i know you're asking
a bunch of tough questions about why i'm
not working with republicans and
why i'm just sort of ramming things
through by executive order and also why
i have this crisis on the board but
listen man i've only been here for six
weeks which is a really disingenuous
excuse from joe biden because he was
vice president for eight years before
the last four years
so he's now been in power nine of the
last 13 years
here's here's joe biden i'm not saying
this is going to be easy george but i do
believe there's enough republicans over
time who are going to have
look you they haven't had that epiphany
you said you were going to see in the
game oh no well i've only been here six
weeks pal
okay give me a break been here six weeks
i think the epiphany's going to come in
20 between now and 2022.
oh don't worry guys he's only been there
for six weeks i mean if this is the
first six weeks
wait to see what you get over the next
couple of years it's gonna get
really really bad over the next couple
years especially because the democrats
are talking
about doing away with the filibuster
which is basically the only check on
democrats adding states to the union
completely federalizing all elections
and therefore screwing up all of the
voting procedures so we have less trust
in our elections ramming down
radical rethinking of the american
way of life with regard to government
cracking down on religious freedom if
this is the first six weeks gang
wait to see what you get over the couple
the next few years
and everybody is happy about this in the
media right everything is fine because
never never forget every everything is
fine on the border even though
everything is disastrous on the border
right now kids are basically being held
in plastic boxes
i mean i'm looking at a picture right
now of kids crowded together under
aluminum blankets
axios has revealed these photos um
doesn't look good gang
kids are basically sleeping on plastic
mattresses under
aluminum sheets in what appeared to be
saran wrap boxes
doctor representative henry cuellar of
texas has somehow gotten in there to
take some of these pictures
but everything is fine everything is
cool we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to an auto parts
store because
never is a great time to go to an auto
parts store you wait in line for a
really long time then you finally get up
to the front
and then you have to answer a bunch of
specific questions and then they either
have a generic part or they don't have
the part at all and they have to order
it online then they up charge you for
the privilege
instead why don't you just skip the
middle man and do what you do with
everything else go to the interwebs
rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same exact apart like say you happen to
need it's just off the top of my head of
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey that'll cost
you like 354 bucks
at a big chain store at rock auto that's
217 you can save yourself a ton of money
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
the prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much
for the same parts the rockauto.com
catalog very easy to navigate
unique quickly see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
choose the brand specifications and
prices
you prefer to go to rockauto.com see all
the parts available for your car truck
and write shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
it so they know that we sent you that
helps us that helps them rockauto.com
remember mention shapiro in there how
did you hear
about us box okay so according to the
washington post
a bipartisan pair of senators called for
more press access to government
facilities holding the rising number of
unaccompanied migrant children arriving
at the u.s mexico border
as they described overcrowded conditions
for minors who are being held days
longer than legally allowed
remember when it was donald trump it's
because he was hitler when it's joe
biden it's just because he's so
compassionate
same exact thing except way more kids
arriving at the border and being held in
cages than any time under president
trump and that's just because joe biden
has such a big
heart this is the beauty of speaking the
vocabulary if you say equity over and
over
if you say yes we love illegal
immigrants over and over and over it
doesn't matter if you're keeping kids in
cages
all that matters for democrats is what
you say not what you do
and then later they can ram down a bunch
of radical policy on the back of what
you say of course
more than 200 border agents have now
been diverted to a cbp
facility to care for children is in el
paso
the children who arrived at the southern
border without a parent are legally
allowed to be held for only 72 hours
in cbp custody before being transferred
elsewhere but many are there for days
longer than that
according to senator shelly moore capito
republican of west virginia
she says i'm very alarmed about the
numbers and extremely concerned about
the overstay in the facility they'll
move 50 out a night and have another 100
come in that night senator chris murphy
of course said these kids are not kids
in so-called cages
but he said they're not facilities
anyone would want your child in for more
than 10 minutes
oh so but um weird because they look
exactly like kids in cages because those
are the exact same facilities trump was
using
but i'm noticing that now you're just
changing the language a little bit to
pretend that what's happening is not
actually happening
nancy pelosi meanwhile from her uh from
her
perch where she has a series of color
coordinated masks which is
interesting she number one she doesn't
need a mask she's vaccinated but it
i will note that every single time she
gets up behind the podium she has a mask
that is color coordinated to her outfit
which is really a nice stylistic choice
you know when she's not eating her
twenty dollar a uh a cord gelato
she's definitely got the color
coordinated mask on with the pearls the
size of your hand
don't worry she's one of the people guys
she says that joe biden has this under
control
that biden administration has this
under control it will take so it is
changed
and it will take some time but it is
values based humanitarian and its
aspects
pragmatic and how to with a plan to get
things done and um not just a
diversionary tactic on the part of the
republicans because they are bankrupt of
ideas on how to improve the lives of
american people
okay i mean nothing there nothing there
we have a plan
so what's the plan our plan is to say
republicans
over and over so here's the thing they
don't have a bogeyman anymore trump is
gone
so this means they have to find another
bogeyman it ain't gonna work
it ain't gonna work at a certain point
you have control of all of the aspects
of american government
you are now responsible you spent years
claiming
that donald trump was evil for keeping
kids in cages
you've got a multiple of the number of
kids in cages now that you did when
donald trump left office
so explain yourself provide a plan but
there ain't no plan
according to the washington post shortly
before christmas last year
susan rice and jake sullivan the two top
advisors to president-elect biden sat
for an interview with efe
a spanish wire service to issue a stark
warning to migrants considering
joining journeying north to the nation's
southern border don't come now but help
is on the way
the next day biden was similarly
appointed saying his administration
while eager to roll back donald trump's
immigration policies first needed to
implement
guard rails to avoid winding up with two
million people on our border less than a
month later
the new president began tearing down
some of the guardrails himself he issued
five immigration executive orders on
inauguration day alone
promised an immigration policy far more
humane and welcoming than that of his
predecessor
his administration also began allowing
unaccompanied minors into the country
a market departure from the trump
administration's approach now the biden
administration is scrambling to control
the biggest surge in 20 years 20 years
with the nation on pace for as many as
two million migrants at the southern
border this year
the outcome biden said he wanted to
avoid
the situation at the border which biden
has and his advisors steadfastly refused
to call a crisis
is the result of an administration that
was forewarned of the coming surge yet
still ill-prepared and lacking the
capacity to deal with it
administration officials have been
plagued by modern messaging sometimes
making appeals that seem directed a more
liberal activist than the migrants they
need to dissuade from coming to the
country and there it is
there it is it's not about helping the
american people it is not even about
helping the migrants it is simply about
pleasing
the left base because the left base is
the media and if the left base is the
media they will constantly defend no
matter what joe biden does the man can
fall down flights of stairs the man can
have a massive migrant crisis on the
border with two million people slated to
arrive this year and the entire
media will continue to massage his ass
because all he does is speak the
language of the vocabulary that's all
that matters all that matters is the
language that you speak
and you will get soft treatment from
everybody on the left side of the aisle
don't worry
he's a transformative president mourinho
assures us he is transformative
he's a magical magical man why because
he says all the right things never
you don't have to worry about the fact
that his fiscal policy makes no sense
we're about to experience a migrant
crisis on the border actually we're
already experiencing that
all of them it doesn't matter that the
man is not with us it does not matter
that the man is essentially a house
plant hiding the water stains all that
matters
is that joe biden says the right things
when he's capable of speech coming out
of his face and when he says those
things
you are supposed to simply repeat and
believe them that's all
joe biden and his administration by the
way are going around saying that the
massive upswell of people arriving at
the border has nothing to do with joe
biden weird because you might want to
ask about the illegal immigrants about
that here's one illegal immigrant
talking to martha raddatz
saying um yeah we wouldn't have tried to
come when trump was president we waited
for biden to be president
would you have tried to do this when
donald trump was president
definitely not definitely we had the
chance
you know the same violence that is going
on today
was there last year we used to watch the
news and uh
i definitely won't do this so did you
come here because joe biden was elected
president
basically basically uh the main thing
was the violence in my country
and the second thing i think was joe
biden
okay look at martha rad it's like oh god
that was not the answer i wanted to this
particular question
over on abc news in an abc news
interview last week
biden said no they're not coming because
i'm a nice guy but that was your entire
pitch
you were the empath in chief right you
were the most empathetic person who
would ever occupy you were the guy who's
going to mourn with us
and you were going to cry with us and
you were going to show the world the
heart of america
yeah you showed us you showed everybody
and now everybody's arriving because
they think that what you said they took
it seriously
it turns out they took you seriously and
literally
wow wow so the democrats are now playing
the game that trump played for a while
right which is take him seriously but
not literally
and the democrats always said people
take him seriously and literally which
actually wasn't true of trump
most people just took him seriously but
not literally because he wasn't
considered a quote unquote serious
person but joe biden is considered a
serious person
which means people are taking him both
seriously and literally as well
so who are you gonna believe the illegal
immigrant who actually tells martha
raddatz i came because of biden or the
dhs secretary who says listen our
messages don't come
no one believes that's their message he
literally said last week
he said last week if you are a migrant
and you arrive you will not be sent home
if you're a migrant child you will not
be sent home is what mayorkas said last
week
here is alejandro mayorkas talking to
dana bash on cnn
we have communicated and we will
continue to communicate
to the children do not come i was going
to mention
about a minute a minute ago that we
encountered three
uh children under the ages of ten three
siblings
uh whose mother was murdered murdered
during the journey
do not come give us the time
to build an orderly system that will
enable
you to make your claim under united
states law without taking the journey
and imperiling
your lives or they could come now
because they don't trust you and they
figure that if they come right now you
will just let them in
why do you think all these unaccompanied
minors are arriving at the border why
aren't they accompanied
right who sends their kids out there
unless they believe that the kids are
going to be allowed into the country and
then they will be used as an anchor
in order for them to bring their parents
over which we all know is what this is
really all about
by the way don't worry the biden
administration isn't letting in the
media either majorca says you know the
media can't come because of covet
oh weird because if trump had said this
you know what you guys would have said
you'd have said that there's a fascistic
tactic directed at limiting the amount
of information available to the american
public
and yet here you guys are saying that
the media can't show up because of covid
we are in the midst of a pandemic
we are dealing with crowded border
patrol facilities
we are focused on our operations and the
needs of the children
and at the same time we are working to
provide
access uh to those border patrol
facilities
when we we can do so in a safe manner
bullcrap
and everybody knows it's bullcrap by the
way fox news now reporting
that a senior source from customs and
border protection says a plan is under
consideration for border patrol agents
in the rio grande valley sector
to begin releasing illegal border
crossers who claim asylum without even
issuing
a notice to appear meaning they
disappear they disappear they just
disappear
they can depart custody no court date so
normally when you show up
and you claim asylum under our dumb
system we don't even hold you until your
asylum court date
instead we issue you a notice to appear
the majority of people who get that
notice to appear show up because they
recognize that if they show up for the
first appointment
then there's there's usually a second
appointment and then many of them don't
show up for the second appointment but
now they are telling people we're not
even going to give you a notice to
appear
you have to initiate the notice to
appear how many people do you think are
going to initiate the notice to appear
how many people who disrespect america's
immigration laws so the extent they just
crossed the border are going to come
into the country and then say you know
what
i really didn't fill out that dmv form
i'm going to head on over and i'm going
to head i'm going to set up a notice to
appear
sure the source says the reasoning for
the decision
is that the situation has become so dire
that border patrol has no choice but to
release people nearly immediately after
apprehension because there's no space to
hold people even to do
the necessary no necessary notice to
appear paperwork
the process of the process of issuing
each migrant an nta can take hours per
individual or family
this would not apply to unaccompanied
minors right now
the rio grande valley is ground zero for
the surgeon border crossings they're
currently at more than
700 over capacity
don't worry guys everything is fine
because joe biden says equity a lot
and barely talks and stumbles downstairs
everything is fine he's a nice man and
because he's a nice man we don't care
whether he is good at his job or not we
don't care whether a crisis
that was a senator it appears that it
was essentially mitigated over the past
couple years because trump said mean
things about immigrants this seems to be
the the main pitch
okay so let me ask you a question if you
have a choice between a president
who says we don't want you here don't
come get out
which is language i'm not totally in
love with and we don't have a crisis at
our border and a president who says we
love you
come on in and then we get a crisis at
our border we know what i care about
from the president
not his feels i care about the policy
that he implements
if you're looking for fueling your
feelings and a president of the united
states get a dog
and a second we're going to be talking
about president biden's economic policy
because we're about to blow out the us
dollar but again all of this is fine
because he's a nice man that's all that
matters
first let's talk about the fact that the
post office great place get a lot of
stuff done there but
you really want to go there why wouldn't
you just use all the amazing services of
the post office you know like at your
house
or at your business let's face it taking
trips to the post office is probably not
how you want to spend your time
that's why i recommend mailing and
shipping online at stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer send
letters
ship packages pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post office and ups
all in one place plus giant discounts on
mailing and shipping rates here at daily
wire
we've been using stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings the service of the us
postal service and ups directly to your
computer
sams.com is a must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices or an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
with stamps.com
you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates up to 62
off ups shipping rates not to mention
stamp.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive
postage meters stop wasting time going
to the post office go to stamps.com
instead
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com promo
code shapiro
stamps.com never go to the post office
again alrighty so
meanwhile inflation is on the move
according to bloomberg.com columnist
john authors
let's make a big assumption we really
are in the process of not only a great
shift toward reflation but toward a new
inflationary regime
what is this like how can we tell what
does the future hold if you want to
argue for a new inflationary paradigm
there's plenty of evidence
this week's u.s purchasing manager
surveys found prices in both the
manufacturing and services sector
at their highest levels since the eve of
the global financial crisis and rising
fast
there have been good these have been
good leading indicators of inflation in
the past
in other words prices are going up
radically which is not a shock because
people have a bunch more dollars have
been blown out by the federal government
by the way you didn't need
two trillion dollars spent the pandemic
is ending we all know that the pandemic
is ending in fact we'll get to that in
just a little while meanwhile
bond yields climb sharply around the
world while yield curves steepen
okay bond yields increase when people
don't want american bonds people don't
want american bonds because they're
afraid they're gonna get paid back in
inflated dollars
in the u.s the spread between two and
ten year yields is the widest in more
than five years
barring only a few days after the
election of donald trump in late 2016.
politicians strengthened traders
convictions wednesday's annual uk budget
which saw promise of even more
aggressive spending suggested that
fiscal and monetary policy will at last
act in unison within the stock market
banks extended their outperformance of
technology stocks
since the start of september banks have
outperformed by almost 50 percent
for four decades inflation has stayed
low and under control while bond yields
have declined
even with the sharp moves of the last
few months these trends remain intact
many forces for deflation or
disinflation also remain in place
workplace automation continues reducing
prices and the bargaining power of labor
but what we could be looking at is a
regime change in real time
we could be looking at a massive
inflation
theodore white wrote a book called
america in search of itself
about the the situation in 1980 he said
inflation has no data beginning
inflation is the cancer of modern
civilization
the leukemia of planning and hope as
with all cancers no one can say when it
begins or how fast it may spread
it's a disease of money when money goes
order goes with it
inflation comes when a government has
made too many promises it cannot keep
and papers
over the shortfall with currency which
ultimately becomes confetti and faith is
lost
okay and this is kind of what we are
looking at right now
inflation psychology is difficult to
change but last year might do the job
and what we are looking at right now
again is that inflation is going to pop
okay it is just going to happen
lawrence summers the former treasury
secretary under bill clinton he says
this is the least responsible fiscal
policy we have had in four
decades in 40 years which would take you
back to
counts accounts at the 70s it would take
you back to
essentially 1970 which is when inflation
started to run out of control
by the end of the decade you had serious
stagflation in which the economy
stagnated because demand started to
decrease but inflation continued to rise
i think this is the least
responsible macroeconomic policies we've
had
in the last 40 years i think
fundamentally it's
driven by intransigence
on the democratic left and
intransigence and completely
unreasonable behavior in the whole of
the republican party
it's driven us to the kind of political
deals
uh that we're seeing okay so i love that
he somehow finds a way to blame the
republicans for a two trillion dollar
bill that was passed
only by democrats that's pretty
impressive stuff right there
okay the demo the republicans offered a
deal right there look summers is a
democrats of course he's
to try to find a way to blame the
republicans we have lit on this
issue zero power in congress none right
this thing is passed
with like a vote from the republicans in
the house and none in the senate
and yet somehow summers is finding a way
to blame the republicans for it this
ain't about the republicans this is
about democrats blowing out the dollar
because they wish to pay you with
dollars that do not yet exist so they
can make you more dependent on
government
and then the answer from democrats to
every problem is more government so when
the economy fails in maybe three years
then you're going to see them claim that
what we need is another bound of
spending we need another
bout of spending we need higher taxes
okay all of this is bad policy and it's
going to have ramifications now think
about fiscal policies it takes a little
while to materialize immigration policy
materializes like that the minute you
say the border is open people rush it
but inflation policy takes a couple of
years to materialize especially when you
have an artificial depression that was
created by covid beginning to alleviate
and so that means that you're going to
have high demand coming out of this
depression
and then what you're going to see is
high growth rates that are tamped down
slightly
by inflation temp down slightly by
increased taxes and then a couple years
down the road
when it turns out that we've blown so
much air into the dollar that the dollar
is worth a lot less and people don't
have savings
and then the demand crashes then you're
gonna see a serious economic problem
it's not gonna happen this year it's not
gonna happen next year it may not happen
the following year
probably by the time you hit 2024 you're
going to be looking
at a pretty serious economic downturn
okay but all of this is okay because
we're just rethinking
the nature of the relationship between
government and the american people
and the media are fully complicit in
this because no matter what joe biden
does he is always just going to claim
that everything is about equity again
recognize the gap between the policy
which is bad and the and the rhetoric
which is exactly what the media want to
hear and what so many people want to
hear these days which is the government
is going to solve all your problems
joe biden is here to tell you that the
era of small government is over
okay the era of small government lasted
basically from reagan
all the way probably until the beginning
couple years of barack obama
even obama in 2004 and even in 2008 used
to talk about how the government was not
there to solve all your problems by 2012
he was saying the government is the only
thing we share
so really by 2012 the year of small
government was over
when we were spending 4 trillion a year
but now rhetorically speaking and
overtly speaking the error of small
government is over joe biden
the democratic party they would love to
completely rethink the nature of the
relationship between government and
american people
government is not only there to solve
all of your personal problems government
is there
to solve all cosmic problems and our
media are fully complicit in this
they love this idea which is why they
are now turning over the keys to the car
to grifters like abram x kennedy you
have to understand how all this ties
together
every max kennedy is the guy who says
that racism just means
stuff he disagrees with racism is any
system that ends
with inequality of outcome any system
that ends with inequality of outcome is
shot through with racism because
otherwise you would be suggesting the
inherent inequality
of human beings now here's the reality
human beings
make unequal decisions all the time
human beings also have different
qualities
some of us are stupider some of us are
smarter some of us are stronger some of
us are weaker some of us are taller some
of us are me
right i mean the reality is that we all
have different qualities and those
manifest in our behaviors
and our decisions manifest in our
behaviors and that creates differential
outcome
even in a free and open system and there
are things that we can do to make sure
that everybody has an
easier shot at getting ahead but the
notion that you can
pick and choose the winners and losers
that is in and of itself
inequitable it is unfair but the left
version of inequitable is
we can just see from the results that
the system itself is broken and
therefore
ibramex kendi gets to dictate to
everyone how the system should work
so as to achieve a completely equal
outcome every max kenny is an
ideological fascist he has openly said
that he wants a department of
anti-racism inside the united states
government answerable
to no elected body of americans that is
created in order to strike down any law
regulation or policy at the state local
or federal level that does not achieve
equality of outcome
which is just called the fascist regime
now imran x kenny is being handed the
keys to the car over
at the boston globes you already have
the pseudo historian
and fiction writer nicole hannah jones
heading up editorial coverage of the new
york times
now you have ibrahim kennedy who is a
grifter of extraordinary
extraordinary rank over at the boston
globe
ben smith writes about this today
ibrahmax kendi and bina
benkar venkataraman met last summer when
their big boston institutions at boston
university in the boston globe were
grappling with protests over racial
justice
miss venkataraman the editor of the
boston globe's editorial page asked dr
kendy
dr kendy okay again ibrahim kennedy in
the same way that dr jill biden
will heal you with a junior college
degree dr kendy
who has no medical degree or really any
degree of any worth in my view
uh he is going to um he is going to
prescribe
racial equity for uh for your heart
attack he's the author of a book called
how to be an anti-racist which is an
extremely racist book
ventacar venkataraman i'm just going to
keep screwing up this name
is going to ask kendy why he decided to
found the center for anti-racist
research which by the way
is this giant catch-all for corporations
just sign a check right twitter
twitter's jack dorsey sent a 10 million
dollar check to kennedy's center for
anti-racist
research which has generated to this
point zero actual research
so far as i'm aware okay so they
so the editor of the the globe's
editorial page asked kenny why he
decided to found the center for
anti-racist research
research in a city known for the
backlash to busting and quote where
sports fans
boo athletes of color she recalled in an
interview they started talking about
their shared obsession with different
boston history 19th century abolitionist
newspapers
then they wondered what it would mean to
found in 2021 a newspaper in the spirit
of william lloyd garrison's legendary
the liberator
well i mean what it might mean is that
you want the races to be treated
the same i mean that's what the
liberator was about right it was an anti
it was an anti-slavery newspaper
i really doubt that william white
garrison was desperate
to segregate the races and then treat
them by race the way that ibram kenny
wants
that to happen but in any case the new
york times reports ben smith
in particular they wonder what would it
mean to bring to american racism the
same sense of urgency with which
garrison in 1831
started in the newspaper abandoning a
more gradualist approach to slavery
now with the backing of their
institutions and a seven-figure budget
millions of bucks they plan later this
year to start an online publication that
blends reportage opinion in academic
research
some of which will appear in the globe
look at that they're just going to
create a partnership where the globe is
taken over by abram kennedy they hope to
revive the tradition of a generation of
media that predates the formal division
of news and opinion in 20th century
american journalism funny how it's fine
when it's on the left if we hit the
daily wire to it by the way
right we openly say we're a conservative
publication a conservative news
organization
then we get hit with fact checks but if
ibram kennedy takes over the editorial
page
of the boston globe or starts a new
journalistic enterprise that blends news
and opinion
that's totally cool and worth
celebrating they want to channel the
energy that has produced a year of
newsroom conversations and arguments
about racism miss venkataraman
said in an interview if you don't have
people agitating for urgent change it
becomes easy to just turn to other
problems
and i think that's sort of an inspiring
framework for thinking about why you
need a publication or platform like this
now
because you need to keep it on people's
minds the past past the news cycle
this of course is not a simple project
the politics of the two venerable
institutions
means the new publication will be hiring
two editors in chief one with a more
academic bent and one more journalistic
a made-up national scramble for
editorials helens
the founders said they'd have
preliminary conversations with cbs's
wesley lowry of course they talked with
wesley lowry
lowry is the former washington post
reporter who has basically argued in
favor of the complete abolition of
journalistic integrity
it's really exciting stuff the project
is backing from the university and
newspaper so bu
is going to be spending money on it and
the boston globe is going to be spending
money on it
and then there's the matter of the name
a christian nonprofit already
trademarked the liberator
so they are looking at the emancipator
but how are they going to use the word
racism should it be reserved for nazis
and klansmen
or and used with extreme caution or
should it be applied as a new generation
of writers have argued to daily features
of american injustice
dr kenny has played a central role in
the debate with his 2019 book
dr kennedy said if there was ever a body
of people who should be arguing out of
the definition of a term
particularly a seemingly politically
charged term like racism why would it
not be
journalists they should define the term
based on evidence
so he just wants his newspaper backed by
the boston globe
to just say that anything is racist that
kenny declares is racist
very exciting stuff really great
self-promotion doesn't come naturally to
dr kennedy says ben smith oh
is that is that right dr kennedy said he
would not police how people use his work
people should be held accountable when
they're being racist but i think people
should be able to repair the damage i
don't view racist as a fixed category
he added he does not believe if someone
said something racist 20 years ago or
even two days ago
right now in this moment they're also
racist that's a lie it's just that he
doesn't want to
he doesn't want this term applied to any
of his friends okay so
are journalistic institutions taken over
by wilkery the biden administration
driven
by wilkery the narratives converge
and so that means that all of this is
secondary understand the job of
democrats and government
is not to create more prosperity the job
of democrats and government is not to
create more safety the job of democrats
and government
is the quest for cosmic justice thomas
swell put it to completely rethink the
nature of individualism and america and
meritocracy in america and if they have
to wreck the dollar in order to do so
that's okay and if they have to wreck
the border in order to do so that's also
okay
so long as you learn the lessons that
you must be taught about social justice
and group dynamics and the reality of
america's institutionally racist
institutions
everything can be torn down to the root
and meanwhile joe biden will provide a
happy face on it because he's the empath
in chief
that's the game here and we all know
that's the game here
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about making
your business better if you're a
business owner who's hiring you'll
probably face a lot of challenges when
it comes to finding the right person for
your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack sure you
can post your job to some
job board but then all you can do is
hope the right person comes along that's
why you should try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you post
a job on ziprecruiter it gets sent out
to over 100 top job sites with just one
click
then zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zipper crew is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options
ziprecruit will find you what you're
looking for the needle in the haystack
again it is deeply important that you as
a company
run your business efficiently and that
means finding the best employees if
you're a prospective employee you need
to find the best companies
zip recruiter makes the magic happen
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free
at this web address zip recruiter.com
dailywear once again
remember head on over to
ziprecruiter.com d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip
recruiter dot com slash daily wires it
requires indeed the smartest way to hire
all right we're gonna get to
much much more because we have a lot
more to talk about there's a long
weekend
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first a reminder you should go
over to dailywire.com right now and you
should subscribe
candace owens brand new show just came
out on friday it is a massive hit it is
charting
segments of it are just charting as a
podcast over at itunes but
people are loving it it's blowing up i
mean the number of people who are
watching candice's show is truly
astonishing
you can only get the full show behind
the paywall so you need to go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code candace for
25 off and let me tell you when you
subscribe you get so much good stuff
i mean all the stuff that we are doing
now we've got all access which means
that you get to talk to all of our hosts
right every night you'll be talking to
one of the hosts over at dailywire.com
hang out with me hang out with walsh
hang out with clayton hang out with
knowles hang out with
candace hey i mean like hang out with
jeremy like all of us
also you get our movie run hide fight we
have brand new entertainment stuff
that's coming into the pipeline as we
speak it's really exciting and really
cool
you're going to want to be able to see
all of that we are fighting back against
hollywood we have a lot of new projects
that are coming up
our readers pass program allows you to
see all of our articles
without actually having to without
having to view the ads or anything like
that we have all sorts of amazing stuff
happening at dailywire.com plus of
course you get the second hour of this
show
there's all sorts of amazing stuff so
make sure that you head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe right now use promo code
candace again because candice's show
just launched you get 25
often amazing deal you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the goal for so much of today's
american left democratic party
the mainstream media their goal is to
completely ignore individual liberty
ignore individual rights
and to remake the country how they wish
it were right results oriented that's
all that matters but not
results as an additional prosperity for
everybody results as in
equity results as in dignity and by
dignity what they mean is forcing you
to cheerlead for everybody else's
self-identification no matter how
ridiculous
and freedom freedom to identify however
you want without any consequences for
the decisions you make
and this means twisting every narrative
every narrative must be twisted
this is how a white guy shooting up
a bunch of asian massage parlors because
according to him
he is a sex addict this is the best
available evidence at this point the
feds are investigating also no evidence
as of yet that this is a quote-unquote
hate crime that was specifically
designed to targeting asians
or that had anything to do with trump or
that had anything to do with the chinese
virus or anything like that
and the media have decided what the
narrative is and the narrative is that
this is indicative of deeper american
racism because when you are attempting
to remake the world
every single piece of data must either
be ignored
or transmuted into a weapon for tearing
down the existing system
this is how you end up with the
narrative this is the but if you ask if
you pulled americans right now do you
think what happened in atlanta is a hate
crime
i guarantee you the vast majority will
say yes despite the fact that there is
no evidence at this point it was a hate
crime
it may have been a hate crime but you
don't know that and i don't know that
and all that matters
is that the media certainly don't know
that and they are lying to you about how
they do know that
so for example you have nancy grace
saying about atlanta it was a hate crime
against women sex workers and asians
okay how about this
how about every single crime is a crime
of hate in some way but you have no
evidence that this was specifically
designed to target asian people
certainly not on the back of what the
left has said that this is about a wide
anti-asian upsurge
among right-wingers okay the the reality
is that the vast majority of upswing
against a violent crime against asian
americans is happening in major cities
not dominated by right-wingers
and according to anecdotal reports
disproportionately from other from
members of the black community
unfortunately
anyway here's nancy grace trying to push
that narrative i think that
most of these women i mean jesse let's
get real you think these women want to
work in a
massage parlor turning sex acts in a
back room with baby lotion heated up on
the side of the bed
no that's not what they want a lot of
them can't even speak english
they can't make a better living they're
kind of forced socioeconomically
into this now they're shot dead
this is a hate crime for sure against
women against sex workers
against asians okay again the broader
narrative that it's about asian
americans and that this shooting was
about that
it may very well have been but let's be
real about this when it comes to the
democratic party
certain types of racism against asians
are completely okay it is only
in the aftermath of this particular
shooting by the way
when the democrats are trying to say
that they are against anti-asian hate
that they've decided oh it's a little
inconvenient to have members of the
of the publicly elected sector who
openly hate asians
so san francisco officials according to
the daily wire including mayor london
breed are now calling on the vice
president of the san francisco school
board alison collins
to resign after tweets emerged showing
her quote-unquote anti-asian bias
the shocking tweets show collins
accusing asians of adopting white
supremacist ideology
and of working to become model
minorities in order to take advantage of
a white supremacist system that she
claims is typically biased against
people of color now let's be real about
this this is something that is a
mainstream thought on the left
many people on the left do not consider
asian americans to be a minority in the
united states
and therefore subjected to hate because
they are the most successful subgroup of
americans
in terms of household income and that is
because there's extraordinary cultural
value placed on hard work
and working toward testing and this has
been ingrained for for centuries in
particular cultures according to
wesleyan
okay so the the insanity of declaring
that asians are basically white because
they decided to take advantage of the
white supremacist systems of the united
states to succeed
all that is is just a again a
reinforcement of the notion that
america's systems are inherently racist
so america's systems are inherently
racist when asian americans succeed and
america's systems are also inherently
racist
when asian americans are
disproportionately targeted on the
streets
amazing how no matter what the no matter
what the antecedent
no matter what the predicate the
conclusion is always the same america is
systemically racist
and this allows you to engage in the
sort of remaking of the world that the
left really wants so in evanston
illinois according to reuters
there's a chicago suburb that now is
going to pay reparations to black
americans
evanston's initial approach to
reparations is narrow and targeted the
city council which has already committed
10 million
over a decade to the effort will vote on
monday to begin with a 400 000
round of payments the first phase will
provide 25 000 to a small number of
eligible black residents for home
repairs
down payments or mortgage payments and a
nod toward historically racist housing
policies now
do they have to prove that these people
were actually victimized by the racist
housing policies
because some of these people i'm sure
are very young some of these people are
probably born in 2000
right at which point segregation in the
united states had been federally illegal
for 35 years in congress a bill that
would establish a national reparations
commission to study the issue has drawn
170 co-sponsors in the house of
representatives
other cities including chicago
providence rhode island burlington
vermont asheville and amherst
massachusetts
have launched initiatives california
passed a bill modeled after the federal
legislation
new york and maryland are introducing
similar measures
the practicality of implementing
reparations programs is still a matter
of debate well first of all how about
the legality of saying that you get
money if you are of a particular race
this is precisely the opposite
of equal opportunity based on race
treating people as individuals requires
that you don't look at their melon level
and then make financial decisions as a
government based on that and yet that is
precisely what these governments are now
doing
in evanston black residents are eligible
for the housing program if they or their
ancestors
lived in the city between 1919 and 1969
or if they can show they suffered
housing discrimination due to the city's
policies
the recipients will be randomly selected
if there are more applicants than
available funds
in the housing program okay some people
are saying it's inadequate
some people are saying it's not gonna be
it and it will never be enough right no
matter what the reparations program is
that is adopted on both a moral level
and a fiscal level it's not gonna be
enough
because if you say give everybody a
hundred thousand dollars people are
gonna say for 400 years of slavery
how can a hundred thousand dollars pay
for that it'll just turn into a
permanent
government check signing program which
is of course on the basis of race which
is precisely the reverse of what federal
law allows
but this is the remaking of america in
real time
on the basis of equity rhetoric that is
essentially unfair that is the goal
and if you don't go along with it you
will be cudgelled if you refuse to go
along with this stuff you will be
cudgelled
the media will simply lie to you okay
when i talk about the cudgeling
let's talk about the cudgeling for a
moment so over the weekend
in what has to be the most amusing turn
the you remember that alexi mccammon was
going to be the editor of of
teen vogue that great prestigious
publication teen vogue not just vogue
teen vogue well now it turns out that
one of the people who backed alexi
mccammon's ouster
a senior tv teen vogue staffer alex
mccabe was thrown out because alexander
mccammon when she was 17 wrote
anti-asian tweets that was a decade ago
now a senior teen vogue staffer who
backed alexi mccammon being fired
it turns out that this lady wrote a
bunch of
tweets back in 2009-2010 using the
n-word
christine david senior social manager at
teen vogue in 2009 wrote two tweets to a
friend
identifying him as a n-i-g-g-a
and in 2010 used that word in a joke
tweet the friend appears to be white
davis david says in multiple tweets use
of mixed irish and filipino heritage
so not a black person so you don't get
to use these sorts of terms right
mccammon 27 and a rising reporter at
axios have been set to take the top job
at teen vogue before her past tweets
set off a firestorm among teen vogue
staff after the atlanta shooting
left asian americans dead mccammon and
teen vogue parted ways
neither david nor mccammon or teen vogue
could immediately be reached for comment
david on march 8 posted a letter on
instagram from teen vogue staff
expressing concern to cons and asked
about hiring mccammon quote in light of
her past racist and homophobic tweets
so proud of my teen vogue colleagues the
work continues davitt wrote
in the caption okay so here's the funny
part okay after alexi mccammon
got fired and many of us on the right
have defended many people on the left
from firing and people on the right from
firing because it turns out that a
culture
in which you can just uncover anybody
those old tweets and then use it to
wreck their career is an ugly and gross
culture
it's not about purity it's not about
making the world better now the left is
getting upset at cancel
culture now the left is getting upset
why because they like alexi mchammond
because alexis mccammon
is on the left so brian stelter who has
been openly leading a charge
to get fox news thrown off the air by
its distributors
now he's like you know what i don't like
this purity culture anymore oh
you you don't brian oh strange so you're
all for the purity culture when it comes
for people you don't like but when it
comes for people you do like
then all of a sudden you're upset with
the purity culture strange how this
works on the left
no one wins in the purity wars no one
wins
of course no one i know would excuse
racist tweets and almost everyone agrees
that we should strive for a more just
equal society
but these internal office battles zap
energy away from the real struggle
i mean no offense to mccammond but her
name should not be on the tips
of the media world's tongues not for
something she did at age 17
so ultimately conde nast failed her
now the real struggle here the real
struggle is getting fox news tossed off
the air
that's the real struggle of course
making sure that
everybody that brian stelter personally
does not like is canceled
and making sure that everybody that he
does like is defended i happen to agree
with him about alexis mccammon but the
point is this he doesn't agree with him
about alexi mchemmon
right he just doesn't like the fact that
one of his friends somebody that he's
apparently friendly with or somebody who
he agrees with
just got ousted from her job and here's
the thing the cancellations will
continue until the morale improves
all the it's funny folks on the right we
have real trouble understanding the left
because we keep looking for the through
line
why is it that alexi mccammon can get
fired but this davit lady probably will
not be fired from teen vogue
why is it that gina carano can get fired
for putting up uh a meme
that included a picture from the
holocaust but pedro pascal puts up a a
picture from the holocaust
comparing american immigration policy to
the holocaust based on a picture that
was not even from america
and he's fine why where's the through
line and the answer is there is no
through line it is all about
pure use of power it is all about pure
authoritarian use of power so for
example i don't see brian stelter coming
out
and defending sharon osborne right
sharon osborne had committed the grave
sin
of having said that she's friends with
piers morgan you're not allowed to do
that
because appears morgan said he didn't
believe meghan markle and you're
certainly not allowed to do that because
meghan markle
is now she's been sainted they're
actually going to they're actually going
to build shrines to meghan markle now so
pierce morgan said he didn't believe
meghan markle by the way for the record
neither do i
on the vast majority of what she said
i'm i'm in no position to doubt her
personal feelings about suicide
but i don't believe that she was deeply
victimized by buckingham palace
i don't think that's a reality i think
that she is on the make
as demonstrated by that interview with
oprah because she's not a very good
actress
piers morgan said that then sharon
osborne said i'm friends with piers
morgan and he's not a racist
and now she's gonna get thrown off the
talk and tiffany cross goes after her so
over the weekend
tiffany cross on msnbc starts talking
about how evil sharon osbourne is
a message to the bigoted brit sharon
osborne
after this read maybe you should go read
because
there are numerous books which greatly
detail how some of your ancestors
colonized raped and pillaged many parts
of this globe
and like you told cheryl don't cry we
toast those tears and continue to do the
work that benefits all people in this
country
even those who don't always deserve it
so
cheerio chap and you're welcome
so so dismissive so derisive so sneering
but remember
she's of the woke so she can say
whatever she wants now if it turns out
she tweeted something bad in the past
she'll be offended because all of this
is just a power game it is all a power
game
all the time and we speak of power games
it's important to note
how the media twists every story into
into this power dynamic
every story fits within this particular
box how does it fit into the narrative
of equity
and and how do we avoid by the way
reporting the real story in order to fit
the narrative of equity
everything is is it's agenda uber alice
it's agenda agenda agenda narrative
narrative and agenda that's all that
matters here which is why you saw over
the weekend a wide variety of articles
about the evils going on
in miami beach you saw a bunch of
stories about miami beach they're
shutting it down because they're afraid
of the kovid they're afraid of the virus
now here's the thing
we've been hearing about death santas
for literally
months at this point like six seven
eight months going all the way back to
the summer
death santas ron desantis happens to be
the best governor in america for the
challenges he faced considering florida
is super
old and it ranks somewhere in the middle
of the pack like near california
in terms of deaths per million and all
of the stories about how tampa was going
to be
the center of a hot spot tampa was going
to be just a coveted hot spot it was a
disaster it never happened
the beaches at jacksonville is going to
be a coat never happened
spring break it's going to be a covert
never happened
so what was the real story here so the
media didn't even get the story right
now
they've they're not just getting the
angle wrong they're just getting the
story completely wrong
so the the story that you have heard
over the weekend is that there is a
panic in florida because of covet and
the miami beach had to shut down
because of the covet risks that is not
why miami beach
shut down the reason that miami beach is
shutting down is because people are
committing crimes
there's open fist fights in the streets
of miami beach okay we are talking about
people running
running up bar tabs of two thousand
dollars and then just running out
like just taking off okay and it just so
happens by the way that these are not
spring breakers who are down from
university
this is people who are out partying end
of story
those people happen to be according to
the miami herald disproportionately
black
according to the according to the miami
herald martin vasalo reporting
after weeks of uninhibited partying on
south beach by spring breakers police
turned away throngs of people many of
them black from world famous ocean drive
with a swat truck
pepper balls and sound cannons the
tactics were intended to enforce an 8 pm
curfew announced only hours earlier on
saturday to rid the city of what police
and politicians have described as unruly
and sometimes violent late-night crowds
the tactics appear to have the desired
effect
but the use of force to clear out people
of color from south beach alarmed some
black leaders
if miami beach has openly recoiled at
the behavior of the at times chaotic
crowds filling the city's entertainment
district every weekend
not just this weekend every weekend
some in south florida are having a
similar reaction to the way the city and
its police have handled the presence of
thousands of people of color
okay so what's the actual story there
are a lot of people of color
in south beach according to the miami
herald and they are engaging
in criminal activity resulting in a
thousand rest by the way there's plenty
of tape that is not being shown in the
mainstream media the mainstream media is
showing tapes of people milling around
like this is the real threat
people milling around that's not why
they put a curfew on they put a curfew
on because i've seen tape
people are at intersections twerking on
the streets and having fist fights like
that's
that's why they put a curfew on and yet
the media won't tell you that they'll
tell you about desantis not about
desantis
what the hell are you talking about
you're just lying about the situation
there
videos on social media showed miami
beach police arriving on ocean drive
saturday evening to find a massive crowd
still on the street
after the curfew kicked in
okay this is again you can see all the
videos
miami beach mayor dan gelber said the
curfew and causeway closing announced
at 4 pm saturday were aimed to prevent
violence and disorder
he described the city as a powder keg
ready to blow residents cheered the
crackdown some saying they're afraid to
leave their
homes okay so um
this is not i'm sorry this is not about
kovid
but if you read the headlines it's about
kovid okay nowhere did the police even
cite kovid
as a risk and yet the idea is that it's
about
this is ridiculous i'm sorry it's not
here is the headline over at drudge the
top headline right now
and from the daily beast south beach
overrun by mask-less hordes yeah that's
the big problem is they're not wearing
masks not the fact they're beating the
crap out of each other and engaging in
criminal activity in miami beach
the problem is they're not wearing masks
it's absurd it's just absurd but again
it has to fit into the it has to fit
into the narrative and what's the
narrative the narrative is that black
people are being cracked down on
by the police and simultaneously
unrelated
cove is a real threat so they want the
two stories simultaneously now the
the police are being mean to black
americans according to miami herald at a
time when the country is undergoing a
racial reckoning the optics of police
officers grappling with crowds and city
leaders condemning a largely black group
of visitors
has been unavoidable daniella pierre
president of the naacp's miami dade
chapter tweeted
spring breaking while black on saturday
night she later added unacceptable to
say the least
okay so again the the problem of course
is that so two simultaneous problems one
it's it's all desantis because look at
these massless people
and two it's the evil police
at no point can you say oh yeah maybe
there are a bunch of people engaged in
criminal activity in downtown and that's
requiring the police to go in because
that would cut against the exact
narrative that they're trying to fight
against
which by the way ties into the broader
narrative here about coven
so they continue to try to panic you
back over they just continue to try and
panic you back over this is the this is
the other narrative
democrats are going to continue to push
the coveted narrative because every
crisis
is an opportunity okay well let's just
be real about this
we are at the end okay we're reaching
the end of the pandemic every person
knows it it's why you've seen a great
opening up
there are more and more solutions being
presented every day
according to the jerusalem post an
israeli company is now claiming
an oral covit 19 vaccine is on the way
apparently they're launching a phase one
clinical trial for what could become the
world's first oral covin 19
vaccine this is auramed pharmaceuticals
a clinical stage pharmaceutical company
based on tech developed by hadassah
university medical center they announced
over the weekend a joint venture with
primus biotech to develop
a novel oral vaccine
apparently they can use this to orally
administer a number of protein-based
therapies
which would otherwise be delivered by
injection
that's pretty amazing nadav drone who's
the ceo
said that they could revolutionize the
marketplace by uniting
he said an oral vaccine could become
even more valuable in the case that a
covenant 19 vaccine may be recommended
annually like the standard flu shot
instead you just pop a pill
it can be shipped at refrigerator
temperatures okay so
we have more and more solutions every
day our great experts are saying there's
no fourth wave remember they keep saying
that the covet
stuff is the reason why we have to be
worried about what's happening in miami
beach when that's really not the story
at all
here's scott gottlieb former fda
commissioner widely
respected in bipartisan circle saying
there's not going to be a fourth wave
well i don't think we're gonna have a
fourth wave i think what we're seeing
around the country is parts of the
country that are plateauing or we're
seeing upticks in certain parts of the
country
i think the fact that we have so much
prior infection 120 million
americans have been infected with this
virus the fact that we've now vaccinated
we've gotten one shot and at least 70
million americans even if you account
for the fact that maybe about 30 percent
of people being vaccinated previously
had covet
we're talking about some form of
protective immunity in about 55 percent
of the population so there's enough of a
backstop here
that i don't think you're going to see a
fourth surge okay not only does he say
that dr ashish
zha who's again a person from the left
side of the aisle
from brown university he says there's
not going to be a fourth wave
we're not going to have a major fourth
surge but what we
are looking towards and what looks like
is about to happen
is we are going to see a significant
bump in cases in a bunch of states
and that means more infections more
hospitalizations more deaths
the reason i'm uh pretty confident we're
gonna avoid what is happening in europe
is twofold
uh one is uh we vaccinated a lot more
people
and second is that we vaccinated a lot
of our highest
people yes correct okay so and by the
way the vaccinations
shut them up the vaccinations are are
not going to
be irrelevant here and yet that is the
line from the biden administration so
you still have dr fauci out there
telling round paul you got to mask up
a year ago this is a direct quote from
fouchy quote i'm confident this virus
acts like every other
once you get infected get better clear
the virus you'll have immunity that will
protect you against reinfection i'd be
willing to bet anything people who
recover are really protected against
reinfection he said that last year
but the narrative from the biden
administration is this is going to
continue it's why we need bailouts it's
why we need to blow
out the dollar it's why you need to wear
a mask until the end of time this is why
you have dr monsev slowly who's the head
of operation warp speed out there saying
yeah you know we should probably still
be wearing masks if you're vaccinated
and you are four weeks after your first
vaccination two weeks after your last
vaccination you are good to go
okay you don't need to wear a mask
anymore dr marty makari johns hopkins
university
because you now have immunity the
studies demonstrate you have immunity
but the narrative has to be that
republicans are evil for saying you
should take off the men we need people
to be scared
the democrats need people to continue
being scared to justify all the crap
that they are
attempting right now fiscally so here we
have dr slough saying we should still
wear masks
as long as the herd immunity levels have
not yet been attained
that people who have been vaccinated
should continue wearing a mask
when in public and in crowded areas
because what we don't know yet is
whether the vaccine
prevents replication of the virus it's
an act of
frankly you know civility i would say
vis-a-vis the people around us who have
not yet been vaccinated okay we know
that people are not transmitting the
virus at like 90
of the rate once they're vaccinated
those studies are out already in israel
they can't cite
a single study suggesting widespread
spread of the virus
after vaccination but they're still
pushing the mask wearing why because
again the goal
is to categorize everybody who's a
political opponent as an enemy of
science you got joe biden out there
saying that he's a friend of the science
incredible
it's incredible they've pushed a bun
he's wearing a mask he's fully
vaccinated
he is fully vaccinated and he is wearing
the mask and he's saying mask up
hey i'm sorry this is dumb it like it
really is at this point
here and you're not encouraging people
to get the vaccine you're telling people
they have to continue wearing the
vaccine forever
and uh here's joe biden the one thing
that
i the reason i am so
so happy to have been able to anyway to
have doc here
is that science is back
no all kidding aside think about it for
the longest time
not just not just as it relates to cdc
but
science science was viewed as
as a sort of an appendage to anything
else we were talking about
but it's back no what what the hell are
you talking about
what are you okay the the sciences
background is the most anti-scientific
it's
they're just anti-science i mean they
really are like for example msnbc's joy
reid
so she says that rand paul won't wear a
mask because he wants to spread disease
like columbus i mean if you just want
the garbage you take
go straight to joy read he wants to be
able to be free to spread code because
remember he had coveted
and showed up in the gym in the capital
gym and felt like he should be able to
be unmasked and spread it there is
almost sort of a a christopher columbus
era attitude toward covet right
if we got coveted you get covet if i got
covered i'm coming in your store
i'm gonna breathe on you and cough on
you if you don't like it you better take
off your mask and take it
there's this attitude that they feel
they have the right to spread coven
or that they're enthusiastic about
spreading covet
okay this is i'm sorry that's so
anti-scientific and insane it's beyond
it's beyond crazy
it's beyond crazy once you've had covet
you ain't spreading it
once you're vaccinated you ain't what do
you think the point of a vaccine is your
morons
my goodness and then i love that she so
she gets the science wrong and the
history wrong
the idea is that christopher columbus
before the the knowledge of germa theory
came to the new world deliberately to
breathe on the natives
and that's just what rand paul is doing
now except the rand paul's immune
and rand paul isn't infecting anybody
but don't worry guys it's all part of
the narrative and the narrative is
america's terrible america's awful and
you need the government to save you from
ongoing crises that aren't crises
at all because they're empathetic guys
they're empathetic
well you know what that empathy is going
to cost you it's going to cost you the
pocketbook it's going to cost you in
freedom
and they don't give a damn about you why
would you think that politicians care
about you
are you a politicians don't give
too craps about you
politicians are people who get elected
to take your money and then spend it on
crap
that they want to do in order to get
themselves paid that's what politicians
are there's a reason people say that
politics is the world's second oldest
profession
okay it's and bears significant
resemblance to the first
the the bizarre nature of americans who
have decided that politicians are their
friends
uh it's it shows the death of community
shows the death of religion and shows
the death of family that's for sure if
you're looking to these people for your
empathy and for your comfort and for
taking care of you ma'am there's some
holes in your life that ain't gonna be
filled by
slow old joe biden stumbling down a
bunch of airplane steps
my goodness alrighty well we'll be back
here a little bit later today with
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
herrera and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant is jessica
crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
joe biden can't walk upstairs the white
house admits there's a crisis on the
border and republican governor christie
gnome
goes weak on transgenderism check it out
on the michael knowles show
you